all right so we have one participant
petrol and uh petrol is uh currently
doing MSC bioinformatics and is
interested in rnac analysis so uh do you
have prior knowledge of our coding
all right so let's start with today's
webinar so hello everyone a very warm
greeting to one and all my name is
Krishna Kumar and I would like to
welcome you all for today's webinar on
biomedical data science in our program
we buy medical data science in our
program is designed for students and
researchers from diverse range of
backgrounds to cover practical and
conceptual aspects of data science
including data wrangling statistical
analysis and machine learning in
application to high throughput
biomedical data more about the program
details will be covered in couple of
minutes the aim of today's webinar is
just to introduce the participants to
program details such as program Mentor
program curriculum overview intended
outcomes and program registrations
I am also excited to announce that today
we will also be joined by Dr Jeet sarkar
senior bioinformatics scientist at
elucidator who will be speaking about
prospective and career opportunities of
data science in healthcare and
biotechnology
so before we begin with today's webinar
let me also take a brief moment to
introduce you to the team behind the
program
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and Commercial collaborators to develop
easy to use analytical tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
and as a part of the program students
will have access to omic's logic
training that has been completed by over
24 000 participants from 187 countries
in over 300 workshops and due to this
fast growth our team is working with
local and Regional coordinators that are
helping refine local program Logistics
and adapting them to the needs of
students and researchers around the
world and this training has been
completed by participants in six
different specialization tracks that
includes oncology infectious diseases
Precision medicine Neuroscience data
science for biomedical data and
comprehensive training on omic's data
analysis
students will also have access to the
omic Strategic resources but how does it
help Advance bioinformatics teaching
omic's logic is a portal for practical
and theoretical learning of
bioinformatics it takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give the student a clear path of the
Bloom's taxonomy pyramid and no matter
what the users initial experience with
bioinformatics is omic's logic is a
useful tool for gaining a baseline
knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of large data
sets and introduction to basic coding
languages like R and python or even
beginning a data analysis project
and this also comes with an access to
omex logic courses which includes
courses on bioinformatics Precision
medicine multi-omics that includes
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics data science that includes
bioinformatics using RN python as the
last game informatics and example
projects of different fields which you
could learn from and replicate for your
research work
users will also be given directions to
access the T buy input platform for
bioinformatic processing and Analysis of
data and the platform includes demo
pipelines as well as data management and
Analysis Cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatic Pipelines
stages of analysis are performed in
different sections on this multiomics
platform so now to view the various
courses and example projects let us
Begin by signing up on the Omens logical
on total
I am sharing the link to sign up on the
portal in the chat box
so I would like to request all the
participants to visit the link and
follow along and sign up on the portal
so for those participants who are
creating an account for the first time
you can click on the option that you see
here that says create an account and
once you click here you will be asked to
enter your name email ID password or you
can also create an account using any of
your social media handles this could be
your Google Facebook Apple account
GitHub account or even Twitter
and for those participants who already
have an existing account on the portal
you can simply click on the login now
option that you will see here and click
on sign in and you'll be able to access
your account so I like to pause for a
couple of seconds so that
um the participants can sign up on the
portal and once you have signed up on
the portal please put a yes in the chat
box so that I can proceed further and
show you various resources that we have
on the portal
all right so one person has pokest I'm
expecting a couple more of yeses and if
you're having any queries you can put
them in the chat as well and I'll be
happy to
um guide you on how to sign up
okay all right so we have couple of
yeses so I'm going to uh sign in on the
portal uh log into the portal since I
already have an account on the portal
and once you sign in you'll be able to
see the various courses and example
projects that are there on the portal so
here if you're looking for a specific
course you can simply enter the keyword
that you're interested for example if
you're interested in machine learning
you can simply enter machine learning
and that will show you all the courses
and example projects that makes use of
the concept
and now coming to the important part
about signing up on the portal all right
several people have signed up that is
great and uh once you sign up on the
portal the important part is that you
need to update your account
so and a completed profile will have a
profile image the name will be in proper
capitalization you should link your
social media handles as you can see uh I
have linked my LinkedIn account and my
work ID and your bio should have your
education background and research
interest
and you can edit all of this in the
profile option that you see here and
you'll be able to enter all of the
details here and update your account
and now uh let's explore what are the
various tabs that we have once you sign
up you have the activity tab here the
program mentor and the community manager
will be tracking your learning progress
on the portal and under the courses tab
you will be able to see the various
courses that you are currently
completing and once you create a
research project and upload it on the
portal it will be visible under the
projects tab and once you end more for
any of the programs for example the
biomedical data science in our program
the program will appear under the
program style and finally after
completing the required courses
assignments and activities you will be
able to receive the certificates under
the certificates tab and with that
um I'd like to pause for a few seconds
if the participants are having any
queries you can let me know
shall I proceed ahead
is everyone good to go
so you can leave a yes in the chat box
all right so uh now I'd like to pass on
the stage to Dr raghavendra and Lakshmi
Narayan who will be explaining about the
program curriculum for the program so
over to yourself
[Music]
thank you very much SRI gauri and thank
you everybody for an active
participation so I would like to know
about your uh Proficiency in r or
encoding in general I think sonalika
already asked this question so quickly
rate yourself in r or in any programming
in general
um so that we can understand uh our
participants in much better way so your
one or two would be absolute newbie and
something like seven to nine would be
you can borrow codes from existing
resources and then modify that for your
data and to answer the type of questions
that you are going to answer so uh
quickly type some numbers so that we can
get going so I am thank you very much
and let me start sharing my screen
great thank you Rakesh
okay can you see my screen I need little
confirmation
yes okay thank you very much so let's go
over the program uh curriculum in
general and then I'm going to show you
where you can access
um
wait a second yeah where you can access
the necessary resources and then we are
going to go over a couple of associated
resources to get you understand how we
have structured the learning resources
and how you can make use of the learn
portal uh to its full potential so this
is the program page and yeah I think you
would have gotten a lot of uh
a link to this let's see
this is where you can access this page
so if you come down this is structured
like twice a week and we start with
giving you a very basic introduction to
uh to the program and also to for
example loading data in R so this is
going to start or help those people who
are starting up there
analysis or starting up their uh
introduction to R so we need we have
given lot of associated resources and
all of you who would want to get some
head start in R so I would want you to
go through these Associated resources
most of them are free because they form
the first two lessons of many of our
courses and they are free in for example
setting up r or using R to load data to
just open up data table in R2 understand
their statistical distributions so
something like that and then we are
going to move over to how you can
produce a variety of of different
structured data from different omics
data analysis this is going to be very
important because as you are going to
use many of these data structured data
in your analysis so we want to
understand how these different data
where these different data come from and
how to use the pipelines from the Big
Data server to produce this structured
data from unstructured data so all of
this will be discussed in the second
session and as we go along then we are
going to introduce you to major types of
machine learning methods where we are
going to discuss an overview about uh
for example different machine learning
tools that are available like
unsupervised machine learning methods
unsupervised machine learning methods
and what you can use how you can use
these methods to answer different types
of questions right different data for
example understanding generally the
separation of samples according to
subtypes or categories present in the
samples can be addressed using a
unsupervised machine learning methods
right if we know little bit about the
data like a prior classification is
available about the data or categories
are available we can use supervised
machine learning to make the tools or
make the model learn from the existing
categories and apply that to predict for
the new ones this will be explained and
discussed in detail in the upcoming
sessions and then we are going to focus
specifically on unsupervised methods and
then supervised methods where we are
going to use for example the similar
date assets to unsubject that to
different types of these algorithms to
compare the their results and comparison
of with their results among themselves
and comparison comparing their results
with existing categories that we can
gather from available Publications or
available information about the data Etc
these will become extremely important
because you will get to choose after
learning these you will get to get the
option of choosing which method and
which
um
further settings or hyper parameters for
each of these methods to be applied to
different types of data for example a
transcript transcriptomics data might
require a different setting and
metagenomics data might require
different setting like most of the times
we are going to use
um linear dimensionality reduction
methods like PCA to understand sample
segregation and to understand sample
patterns in the transcriptomics data but
for a complex data like metagenomics
data a simple linear method of
combining the features might not work
very well so we have to apply different
types of non-linear data Dimension
dimensionality reduction methods like
tsne like MDS and nmds methods for
understanding the patterns in the
metagenomic data so these things will be
discussed in detail and will be shown
how to perform this analysis in in R
using our codes and also you can start
if you want to understand the logic you
can start with performing this analysis
in the turbo bioinforce server uh Big
Data platform so that you have a um have
a reference output of how the result
should look like then you can modify or
you can understand the e-networkings
with the code and then the same is what
we are going to do with a supervised
machine learning uh or classification
algorithms where we are going to start
with absolute Basics like using binary
decision trees which will ask simple yes
or no questions to classify your samples
into the types that you are going to
make the model learn from and then to as
complex as we will use random forest and
and uh yeah LDA SDA and support Vector
machines Etc in the end yeah the idea is
to understand the limitations and the
advantages of these methods separately
so you can pick or you can actually opt
for the perfect method for the perfect
type of analysis right and that is going
to maximize the information content and
also minimize the computational
complexity of what you're going to work
with so this will be very important for
example if you want to um
classify let's say tumor samples into
their subcategories right we can use
different tools depending upon the
complexity of the data in terms of
number of genes for which the
categorization is done for if you have
for example 20 000 genes then machine
machine learning method like support
Vector machine might not be very
accurate in in understanding the
patterns of the data so we might have to
subject either subject the method or
subject their data into some sort of
feature detection or feature selection
methods before applying sub support
Vector machines and LDA and Etc so these
methods and how to perform this and what
are the advantages of doing this and how
to effectively interpret the output most
importantly will be discussed in the uh
sessions that deal specifically with
particularly with unsupervised and
supervised machine and then the last two
sessions are extremely important because
that is going to show you how to combine
these different methods that you have
been learning so so far right first to
effectively answer a question right and
two two for example to select a specific
data and specific project that is going
to involve a detailed uh methodology
with uh selected machine learning
analysis to answer a question of your
own so the last session is to provide an
introduction to how you can access
different publicly available resources
to select a specific type of data or
a set of data it doesn't have to be one
data it can be uh data from a couple of
other resources also and then
effectively use that for the question
that you want to answer maybe my data
set can come from
a repositories like gene expression uh
Omnibus like ncbi gene expression
Omniverse which is going to
predominantly uh give you information
about the transcriptomics data that
several Publications actually use it for
their analysis I can collect
transcriptomics data for let's say
um a neurodegenerative disease a set of
transcriptomics data that deals with
neurodegenerative disease to understand
for example
um majority of the genes that are
um
involved let's say in in the mechanistic
aspects of these neurodegen diseases or
I may be interested in for example a
mass collection of cancer data which you
can get from tcga and then use it for uh
for further uh understanding the tumor
subcategories or categories of tumor
tumor types and yeah these kind of uh
discussion on what data to acquire from
where and how to use that data to answer
a question that you are interested in
and that will be interesting to many
other people in the uh in a project that
uses machine learning will be discussed
in the last two sessions right basically
so for today I am going to for example
um mainly discuss with data processing
and visualization so it all starts with
loading up the data and understanding
the patterns of the data and why should
we do that why should we pre-process the
data if the machine learning methods are
so Advanced and so in intelligent oh so
smart then what is the necessary to
perform this data processing so the need
for processing this data is actually
given or discussed in extreme detail in
the bio ml course 7 in lesson number
three so that is what we are going to
deal with let's let me share the
link once it's loaded once it's loading
for me
yes so this is where you can load this
this is uh made free for all of you to
explore uh and understand the necessary
or the need to prepare a
data that is actually reflective of the
patterns that is present in the data so
I mean you can read through this passage
but this one picture is sufficient to
give you the message right irrespective
of the type of model that you are
building either it is more complex or
more simple it's a good model or a
statistically accurate model
mathematically a valid model
it will return garbage results if you
are going to give a data that is
unprepared or data for example that is
filled with technical noise or data that
is completely inconsistent and data
sometimes it has duplicated information
right so these are not good so following
along what actually constitutes a good
data or rather what actually constitutes
a bad data when when you should raise a
red flag if you see some patterns in the
data so this these are all very
important points that you should keep in
mind so this will not only affect your
machine learning model but it will
affect your Downstream analysis in
general so these types of bad
characteristics of the data that we
don't want in any of our data analysis
so for example we don't want um uh
signal to noise ratio be very low so
that begs the question then how can we
estimate this signal to noise ratio how
can we how can we find out whether my
data has a lower signal to noise Ratio
or a higher uh signal compared to the
mice so uh we will discuss this in in a
short while and then coming down whether
most of sometimes my um omics data can
actually have missing data or depending
upon the type of processing that it has
already undergone it can have imputed
data right
um why we are actually dealing with this
because for for data science
applications we will mainly discuss or
we will mainly
deal or um we are going to deal with
data that is pre-processed and available
at uh at a different data repositories
because our idea is to collect as many
data as possible so that that our model
can understand the um patterns that is
available in the data so in that case
when you are collecting data from
different several different resources or
collecting data that is produced in Mass
there is chance of this some of this
data can be
was not recorded well or is is actually
missing so we need to know about how to
handle this missing data and how much of
the percentage is actually acceptable
and when the percentage becomes higher
what should we do about this missing
data so we will discuss that also in in
the sessions in detail but we will
quickly go through uh in the next few
minutes also so for example we might
encounter data with batch effects that
is for example a consistent difference
between sample because of they are
measured in two different places or they
are measured by two different persons
etcetera and we can we will definitely
for example deal with sometimes we might
deal with samples that are mislabeled
because labeling is done by people and
we have to give some sort of error
percentage that can arise from labeling
from Human cases right so
these are all some of the red flags or
these are all some of the important
points that we want to verify whether
our data has such bad qualities and if
yes what are we going to do about that
right and this is what is addressed in
exploratory data analysis right and
where you can subject your data to a
myriad of different plotting methods and
visualization tool that is going to help
you each and every one of this answer
whether my data has any mislably whether
my data is of low quality whether my
data has follows any for example uh
ah any required data distribution like
many of the statistical methods might
require your data to follow a gaussian
distribution so whether that is actually
followed or not so these are the kind of
answers that you will uh get when you
are going to work with
um data visualization and exploratory
data analysis and most importantly
sometimes as I mentioned we might have
to collect or gather data from multiple
different resources and also even Within
These one single resource the data might
not be in a format that we want it to be
so in that case how to
um
convert the data into correct format and
what constitutes the format that we
require the data to be in to be used by
Machine learning analysis Etc so these
also they are also very important and by
now you would have guessed that
um using data science methods for
biomedical data actually deals with more
data pre-processing rather than applying
the data science method so majority of
the work is done before applying many of
these
um more to be discussed machine learning
tools on your data so the data has to be
prepared well the data has to be
understood very well before subjecting
that to machine learning tools and
methods to answer our type of question
so that is very very important so this I
am going to stop with this for this
lesson here but you are extremely
welcome to go through this this whole
lesson which is very very informative
because uh in the next section we are
going to show you or introduce you to
one of the most used data set created of
data sets from our portal which deals
with breast cancer cell line omics data
analysis where it is where we have seven
different types of molecular profiling
done on these breast cancer cell lines
in addition to
treatment response data is also
available so you can start as simple as
performing visualization options to
understand patterns in the data
exploratory data analysis and as complex
as using this data for multi-ohomics
data integration and
um
find out for example the cell lines that
are going to respond positively to a
given treatment or that's a length that
are not responding to any given
treatment given set of treatments so
this and more about this specific
project is actually given in detail in a
s in a separate project if recovery can
paste the seller in pdxlm project that
will be great so where we take this data
and explain you in detail about what
this data is actually telling you what
this paper is actually telling you and
then we use unsupervised unsupervised
machine learning methods to understand
patterns in the data and to help you
get a good um introduction to how
different machine learning methods can
be used to answer key questions in using
data from publicly available resources
okay let's find out this data
into the Excel line okay it's not coming
okay
um
thank you thank you very much for that
yeah so you can get that so for the next
part for the next five minutes or 10
minutes I have so we are going to having
established the necessary to necessity
to perform
um
um exploratory data analysis and pre
preparation of data then we are going to
go to another Associated resources which
is going to deal with our coding course
2 and we have made this lesson three
Advanced Data visual decision free for
you to explore again and yeah let me uh
go through that lesson and that is given
in this
uh
if I can paste this link here yeah so
this is given free so we start with
understanding the format of the data
right so you can view the full table
here so when I spoke about different
formats of the data this is what I
actually mentioned so we want the data
to be in proper uh columns and row
format so you are you are free to
download this data and open it up in
Excel and and notice generally about
this data this is a curated data set
which is straight away from the cell
line project and that is going to have
or fulfill certain
um that's going to have process some
characteristics that we will explore
using these data exploratory methods so
what are they first we have to load them
to understand or to understand the
patterns in the data so the first part
is going to deal with how to load this
data from your computer into RS
environment so if you are absolute
newbie to R this is where I want you to
start this is already the third lesson
in this course so the first two lessons
are going to have even basic steps on
setting up r or loading the data and
then verifying whether all parts of the
data is loaded perfectly or not so I
want you all to start there if you are a
new b2r and then for example
cleaning the data you can notice or you
will definitely notice in this data set
we have some n a values or some
incompleteness in this data so how are
we going to deal with that so if you
have this incompleteness do we here in
this specific data right we are going to
exclude them and in the session that is
going to deal with this specific lesson
then we will discuss about
why excluding these n a values is a
better choice than doing anything else
so that's what we will do if you or
googleide or Kenai you can see that
after performing this
in incompleteness exclusion we are
actually left with 992 rows earlier we
were left with 1000 row so we have
completely disregarded eight genes for
their information because they have
partial information and then comes a
myriad of statistical visualization tool
like we can perform subject this
analysis subject this data to box plot
right and this is going to show you
start like this that's going to show or
tell you about the data distribution in
general right and what do we need to do
for the box plots to look like this
right we have to transform the data into
logarithmic format because the existing
format of the data does not follow a
gaussian distribution which is
absolutely necessary for majority of the
statistical test and Analysis
uh okay Kashi says he is not able to
hear me I hope many of you can hear me
very well
please check your audio settings yeah so
this couple of box plots from your data
generally without subjecting it to any
sort of pre-processing is going to tell
you that the data is not normally
distributed or does not follow gaussian
distribution so for that case we will
simply use a logarithmic transformation
of the scale of the data and then we can
make the box plot which is going to tell
us about the data for example it's going
to tell me that most of the
non-malignant samples has a median value
or median expression value that is
little bit higher than the chlorine low
samples and we can already see that
there is one non-malignant sample which
doesn't fit with the other four so these
are all some of the clues or insights
that you can generate after making a box
plot
like this and this doesn't start stop
with box one right you can also make a
box plot by grouping the information
that is present in different samples
because since these are all biological
replicates of sample under one condition
we can group them together that is going
to give us some more information so I
want you all to explore this specific
lesson because we have let it free for
24 hours so uh this has much necessary
or much needed are codes in this lesson
and if you scroll down it's going to
give you
um insights into what you can learn
about scatter plot and how more
importantly how you can
visualize or how you can visualize your
data using scatter plot on what you can
learn from scatter plot or options like
bar plot or options like for example
come down you can use a histogram right
and one of the most useful
options in this
um
in this learn portal is a practice
session sections right in all the coding
sections there are other ways of
transforming the data from log
transformation you can normalize the
data using quantity normalization right
so we can discuss that also in the
um or z-score normalization is another
way but Quantum normalization and logs
log transformation will
take care of most of the
distribution issues right and yeah most
useful section in this is going to be
practice the code section where after
you have learned to for example load
clean and visualize the data this is the
place
uh that that will be explained in more
detail in the separate section section
because if we go there then it's going
to take long time and it is also
available in this uh lesson that we have
given free so feel free to explore and
understand how this transformation is uh
how this transformation is actually
um done and what are the advantages of
that so I want to show you about this
practice code section where it's going
to load our console from our server and
you are free to for example run codes in
this section so for you to get a clear
understanding of what we have actually
discussed so far we have left out little
bits and pieces of these codes here so
so that you can verify what have learned
in the above sections for example if you
just run these codes as it is it's going
to throw you an error it is error
running code so if you read it says we
have actually made some of the syntaxes
incomplete and please complete those
missing parts based on what you have
learned so far so I'm going to check if
there is anything incomplete in the
first uh uh line looks like the first
line is actually incomplete the
separator is not actually mentioned uh
the separator is a tab separated format
right and uh most uh as you would have
learned from the above section and the
rest of the section is true okay let's
run this again let's see you can clear
the output of the console by clicking
this and then learn it again
and now again it's giving me some error
so let's check the other ones okay this
seems to be fine and now okay this part
is incomplete where I have to check the
dimension of the data the data is not at
all mentioned so let's mention the data
and clear it and then run it
then I get the uh
necessary feedback that I have been
successful in running the code and the
answer is and the answer is correct
sometimes you might encounter for
example uh
options like the answer is correct let's
see that for example here
um
so if I do this if I run this it's going
to tell me error running code okay I
just wanted to show you for example here
let's see that let's see that if this is
a test case
and let's see you say it is also saying
error running code okay
why is that the case
okay I just wanted to show you but
sometimes if there is no problem in your
syntax it's going to show you success in
running the code but the answer is
incorrect that would mean that you don't
have any syntax error but you have some
error in which in where you are
generating the output so you want to
check your syntaxes and run it again so
that's what I wanted to describe but
looks like I'm not able to do that but
yeah you can actually keep exploring
this I want to stop here due to time
concerns but
um this is going to also open up
assignment for you where we have given a
complete console free for you to explore
where you can took or pick bits and
pieces of the code that you have learned
from the previous sections and then
create or complete the assignment as you
can see from here and for example if you
come down
you will have advanced uh visualization
option where you are where we are going
to introduce you to alternate way of
visualizing these tools which will be
extremely useful to for example
um
fine tune the visualization to uh to
produce publication quality
visualization right and we have given
practice sections for visualization this
also right where you can get the two get
the tool to run and create an output
here which you can download or which you
can visualize whether it's uh working
perfectly or not that's what I wanted to
show you and with that let me hand this
over back to srigori and sorry for
taking five minutes extra and if you
have any questions I'll be happy to
resolve it here
or if you have more detailed questions
then I will be very happy to answer that
during our sessions uh in the program
thank you
all right thank you so much sir so uh
there is a query in the chat like how to
complete the program uh side LM first
you need to enroll for the program we
will be discussing about the program
registrations in a little while and
meanwhile we are waiting uh let me just
share my screen
and uh
is my screen visible
yes regard it is
all right so uh for the next part I'd
like to invite Dr Ajit sarkar uh he is a
physician scientist with a keen interest
in data analytics and precision medicine
he's passionate about finding meaning
out of biomedical data and leveraging
them for better clinical outcomes and
his current work generally involves
offering meaningful and translational
guidance to biological and Healthcare
organizations currently working as a
senior bioinformatics scientist I am
sure we will be able to learn a lot
about the field and the opportunities
that the field has to offer and with
that now I'd like to pass on the stage
to Dr Ajit sarkar to start with today's
expert so over to you sir
thanks thanks so can you hear me yes sir
okay
so let me share my screen
I guess you people can see my screen
yes sir yes
yes sir okay so hi so
uh thanks thanks for the opportunity to
uh
to speak at this webinar so I know it's
a very interesting webinar I will talk
mainly just to give a very uh basic
introduction of Health informatics
so as all already mentioned uh I come
from a very um sort of a maybe a
different background so I have done very
basic clinical degree mbbs almost seven
years back
my interest was always on data and data
analytics so after mbbs I shipped it I
still shifted towards doing my PhD in my
informatics and data science
So currently I work as a senior
scientist and I handle multi-oh mixed
data which ranges from
transcriptomics proteomics metabolomics
and I also work with EMR data health
record data and the building predictive
models after those data and also to
provide Solutions customer Solutions as
per their need so this course is going
to cover more or less
[Music]
I will I will limit myself to the genre
of Health informatics so it's more more
of a healthcare data science
so I won't speak at length on
transcriptomics or other multi-omics
biotech related omics things
and today is the introduction so just
let me start it so I have just prepared
a few slides for to for today's top I
have briefly divided them into three
sections experiences my experiences data
science in healthcare where it stands
today and some of the challenges and
opportunities which which are still now
and which will be coming more in the
coming nearby future
so uh so starting with uh this has been
my journey so if you see uh it's more of
a transition from Healthcare delivery to
healthcare research so as I have told I
have done my graduation from uh in mbbs
and then afterwards I did my clinical
residency it's more of a physician kind
of role where I used to treat patients
and attend to patients like that
to clinical research uh the research
question was was majorly Clinic Al
practice driven and I had my major focus
on type 2 diabetes uh almost uh six
years back now from Clinical Research I
slowly shifted towards bioinformatics
and then Health informatics so why am I
giving this particular particular slide
and so the the idea is to tell
any learner from any age in any stage of
his or her career or education that you
can you always have the option to switch
and shift from domain to other domain
and given and today given the amount of
resources you can access to open source
resources
resources like Pine biotech so it's very
easy given you have the motivation and
the right choice of your goal you can
also do such short open switches so
again my graduation my clinical
residency and clinical research this was
main majorly for Academia so I had spent
almost six years you can tell in
Academia
research I I spent the coming five years
there would be overlap between Academia
and research and only for the last two
years I have been into the industry now
again why do I mention this also because
now nowadays things are coming surfacing
out that there is a big gap in Academia
and research and Industry and maybe
there are certain skill sets which
Academia doesn't Empower with us which
we need for the industry but still there
is plenty much opportunity to upskill
yourself to learn new things and these
might not be a very abrupt Journey for
some might be very abrupt for some and
there's always hope to trans transform
you yourself from Academia to research
to Industry so there are options so I
would just tell everybody to explore
more and more and things are not that
much of difficult and critical as it
might look you just need to be
consistent and things will surely work
out
so again the next thing is what did I
learned from Academia so is it nothing
that Academia didn't uh teach me or
there are something so yes there are
some things so in Academia is actually
the place where you where you go to know
the basics of biology so in my case
biology so the basic thing so what is a
cell what is the tissue what is the
organism what is the gene what is a
protein what is transcription
translation
what is transcription regulation so this
very basic basic things this nobody is
going to teach you nobody is going to
spend the effort to teach you these
basic building blocks is what Academia
can only teach you so from my
perspective IU so I got into the basis
of biology
music of medicine then health and
disease what is a disease how how do we
Define disease
and for for my special for my particular
specific background clinical approach to
medicine and public health approach to
medicine so this is more of a
professional degree so while I just
learned what to do and what not to do I
had a I had a very limited scope of
innovation or innovating or learning new
things or tilling or discovering new
things something which I could achieve
in my research during my PhD so so from
this academic background I strive to
[Music]
zoom in one or two questions one or two
pertinent problems and I I was taught
the taught the art of quantifying things
in my research so now I learned so
amazingly I focused on quantitative
methods so how do we quantify medicine
how do we quantify a problem how do we
quantify uh suppose RNA expression in
normal cell versus RNA expression in a
disease tissue so this art of
quantification that involves
pre-processing processing and downstream
analysis so this quantitative approach
to medicine is what a research taught me
now that was also something uh
incomplete until I came to Industry
where I could bridge the gap between
Academia and research and make it into a
product a product that will be serving
purpose of multiple people
so this journey from Academia to
research and Industry this has been
quite uh quite a uh I would tell
diverse Journey quite a exciting journey
and there are things which you get to
learn only in that duration of your life
in that duration of your career and you
should try to make the most
from wherever and whenever you are
right now
so now coming to the next uh big section
is data science in healthcare and
biotech so where we are right now
so this is the this is a very uh this is
a survey market analysis done by uh
um McKenzie and company and they had
tried to identify the amount of Ventures
Capital which has been invested in AI
companies who work in healthcare
over the last maybe five to seven years
so and you see there are three uh three
large U.S Europe and Asia and this is
the uh number this is the Venture
Capital amount invested and you can see
the growth the growth is actually uh
tremendous so between uh these four
years that that has been a growth of
five weeks 22x for Euro and 28 x for
Asia so the growth would be is going to
be
massive in healthcare domain
Healthcare data again Healthcare data is
a big big source of data it requires
tremendous amount of data storage and
data Computing facility and with the
modern day computers all the GPU chips
and all those things cloud computing uh
the the healthcare data handling
capacity has increased but what we what
we are lacking is a proper human
resource who who will be well equipped
to handle this Healthcare data and
that's something which is uh which is
still uh pending and that will come in
the coming maybe one decade and this
would be the major things of healthcare
AI Solutions we can do chronic Care
Management so in any chronic care it's
diabetes hypertension heart disease or
arthroat sclerosis in any chronic Care
Management data and data driven decision
is what is going to be the future of
Health Care
self-care prevention Wellness so
self-care Edge as we entered in as the
demographic shift occurs so we will be
having much more geriatric population in
the coming one or two decades and so
geriatric population who will be
requiring more prevention more self-care
more home based health care so that's a
very important area for healthcare AI
prize and diagnosis again as so uh as
the as the disease burden increases we
have to stratify patients into high risk
moderator risk low risk and we have to
design the health care in such a fashion
at high risk patients get more attention
compared to low disk or moderate risk so
this triage and diagnosis is also
something very very hot right now
diagnostic so
covida kovid era and all these things
have shown us that that diagnostic these
rtpcr kits these are a very uh such a
domain of AI where Healthcare is going
to succeed clinical support So as doctor
and patient ratio becomes more and more
disparent as the patient burden
increases or a particular physician
clinical decision support tools will
surely come into place and Care delivery
is also something where point of Care
Home Based care these are very in very
primitive stage right now but that is
also where something uh where AI is
going to Mark put some marks so this is
the broad broad spaces where Healthcare
is going to transform
and if I just tell you from the company
name so this can be the I guess top 50
companies with the headquarters and
total amount of million raised so you
can you can see that almost uh it's
eight four nine zero million dollars
which is the top uh 50 funding reported
and the top 10 has around so around 58
percent of this entire funding which has
been raised so it's a it's a big
investment from the budget PC funding
and opportunities and solutions will be
massively increasing so we also need to
you know to prepare ourselves with the
right kind of knowledge and expertise
so now how data science can transform
Healthcare so just going to a bit of
more granularity right now so the first
thing is patient here so Healthcare
Healthcare uh the the central character
in healthcare is a patient
so data science would be successful if
it can transform health health care by
giving better and quality patient care
so what are what can be the key areas of
delivering good patient care so it can
be it can be there can be multiple of
things in this particular area
uh so managing appointments and clinical
message so there's something called uh
waiting time and this is a very
important marker of a
truly skilled Hospital facility uh where
the waiting time is minimal or the the
less the waiting time the better is the
facility and this is the better the
delivery service the bit at the footfall
so managing appointments and clinical
receipt precise Diagnostics so there is
something called proficient medicine
which is coming up in the last uh
five to six years and now people are
telling that no one disease is actually
one disease it's a cluster of multiple
diseases so arriving at precise
diagnostic using uh transcriptomics data
proteomic biomarkers
arriving at precise diagnostic will help
in the delivering precise treatment and
better recovery
early disease prevention prevention is
going to be the going to the next big
thing so right now we were focusing
mostly on key order so disease occurs we
have to cure it but even at a prevention
stage
things are now coming up that people are
talking about prevention that if you can
if you can have some biomarkers who is
biomarker Will will tell you that this
person is going to going to have a high
risk of type 2 diabetes in 10 years then
you will be following uh lifestyle
modification at a much earlier stage
so right now what happens somebody is
diagnosed with that up to diabetes and
the physician tells the person to modify
the lifestyle do some Diet restriction
and exercise but things are but info
reports and Studies have reported that
this may not be that much of helpful
because the pathology and the damage has
already been done so people are telling
that the damage occurs at least one
decade before the disease actually
manifests or shows up so prevention is
important so we can prevent it at a much
earlier stage and maybe these lifestyle
modification may be implemented one
decade back that will of course increase
the efficiency and reduce the mortality
Mobility there are certain metrics to
calculate uh
a good lifestyle and all those things so
prevention is a very important thing
which is coming up
so as I told that stratification
classifying patients into high risk load
is moderate risk and thereby providing
them care is what is called patients and
imaging and Diagnostics so as you know
much of the Imaging right now suppose a
CT scan USG MRI they already have some
computationally uh computationally
calculating thing which already
diagnosed so ECG already comes with some
automated Diagnostics Automotive reports
now Medical Imaging is a a big booming
field and in the era of kovit the thing
was that to know that this patient is
suffering from kobit rtpcr was taking
suppose close to two to three days
so for three days was a very quick very
critical time for a particular patient
in that case in that scenario people
were talking out talking about image
based and Diagnostics where based on an
extra image if you can identify whether
it's a covet case or a non-covet
pneumonia and that that that to do that
we need lots of deep learning
algorithms and deep learning algorithms
with lots of image data with a proper
complete facility so this is also
something which also is coming up
the next big thing is business business
and management so this has nothing to do
with the patient care but again has much
to do with the patient care also so what
are the uh big things if I can just tell
in one two three four five so first is
process automation
so suppose uh this uh this so Robotics
and these things will also fall into
this category so Suppose there is one
thing called uh
Diagnostic Lab trade around time so when
a sample is being collected from one
particular patient now that that sample
has to reach to the lab and the test
needs to be done now the smaller this
particular the mean the minimum this
particular time uh the more correct the
diagnostic result and there are already
automated things so it is a sort of
tubular
channels in the hospital so when you
collect the blood you just put it in a
you just put it you just open a hole in
the sort of a door in the window in the
uh in the in your wall and and using
suction technology it will automatically
take the particular while into the
Diagnostic lab which is which is located
in the tensor of the building so this is
a very uh very used example of process
Automation and we can we can use similar
automatic robotic Based Services for
healthcare or Administration claims
Administration so claims and medical
claims and medical insurance is a big
thing right now in the U.S in the Europe
it's already a big thing and the India
it's already coming up so claims records
are again massive Healthcare records so
extracting relevant information from
Planes claims history and then
calculating the premium amount
Healthcare premium premium amount and
all those things is a big thing and
claims and claims record Administration
is a big uh invites a lot of talent and
there are they are already trying to
automate the entire process to to
increase the claim settlement or claim
premium premium calculation time so
suppose you come with a claim uh history
of uh 100 pages so instead of going
through it
manually if there was a system which
could which could automatically scan it
extract all the important relevant terms
and then calculate a score of your disk
and then calculate the premium amount
that would be increasing the uh claim uh
claim adjudication and all those things
chat Bots as we are as we are going to
more and more mobile Based Services so
chat Bots and business insights these
are also some important questions in the
in business personal management
lastly we come to Pharmaceuticals so
Pharmaceuticals also includes vaccines
as well as drugs in my case and Drug
Discovery as you already know drug
Target Discovery uh drug Target
discovery that involves finding out
particular gene or genes which are
important in the disease State compared
to a normal State then finding out drug
molecules and drug and without the drug
molecule and the drug Target are
properly aligned or docking is using
docking techniques so those things are
studied here planning Logistics and
improving clinical trials so clinical
trials is something it's a big it's a
big
sort of a revenue burner in the
pharmaceutical industry so much of the
revenue of much of the investment goes
to the designing clinical trials and
improving clinical trials and this is
something also clinical trial data
ability to analystical trial data is
also something which is uh which needs a
bit of AI and data science right now
so now the challenges so for now as you
know the more the problems the diverse
the data field the more the challenges
and the first challenge which is a very
big thing in data quality is and data
infrastructure so data quality is
something which is very critical in
health informatics so we have we lack
quality data aggregation as a integral
part of healthcare delivery so suppose
people captured Healthcare data as a
part of healthcare service so they are
rendering some service and in that
course they capture Healthcare data so
Healthcare data capture is more of a
secondary purpose and that what makes
the quality questionable and doubtful in
some cases
so that that's a big challenge because
models any AI model any ml model you
can't build a good AI or ml model with a
bad data so the assumption is you are
having a very good quality data and then
only you can build a proper AI or ml
model and the next thing is the lack of
fairness for healthcare data sets so
what is fairness where so fair principle
is something which applies to the
biological domain so data should be
findable accessible interoperable and
reusable so and data should be used so
some so one hospital at maybe and in
India is capturing clinical data One
hospital in Singapore is capturing some
clinical data one in the London and one
in the New Jersey so now these four
these four uh hospitals would be having
different standards different uh
different structures of the clinical
data but if you wish to merge these four
data sets then you have to reach to a
standard procedure and this is a big
challenge so people will be capturing
data in different different pattern and
pattern and Fashions and you have to
make those data you have to curate the
data and you have to make it
standardized and harmonized and a lot of
time goes into this particular and data
verification for healthcare data
there are solutions so the first
solution is building more clinical
resistance so clinical Registries are
actually
a pre-planned pre-planned data records
so it's not that you are providing
Healthcare and you are capturing data as
a secondary thing not not that you you
capture data that's your primary goal
and in the course of data capture you
also provide Healthcare but it's a very
costly thing to do Implement and
maintain and the next thing is preparing
a proper ontology for fair and data sets
so that what the hospital in Delhi those
patients suffering from type 2 diabetes
with diabetic retinopathy you you can
also get a similar set of patients with
a senior center diagnosis from other
locations also so given you your
property you are doing a standardization
of this disease column so you can map
multiple digits you can Club diseases
and you can do a large scale combined
analysis
the next challenge is actually
compliance and governance because you
know data Healthcare data is very uh is
very restricted and very sensitive
so and there are very complex regulatory
guidelines for healthcare data storage
collection and utilization like HIPAA
gdpr and cpgr
so there are lots of techniques which
people developed suggested
but it's not a very straight card
solution so the something is something
called predicted language so inflated
learning so generally when we build a
model we take data from multiple sources
we we stored them in a central Depot and
we run the model there we built the
model there we run the model there
but but in case of Affiliated learning
we don't do that
the data resides into the local server
the model is built into the in the local
server and the model gets deployed and
implemented there also they are there
only but the model parameters
will be only the model parameters will
be stored into the central server so no
data is stored centrally all data
resides locally in the particular
Hospital in their servers only the
modern parameters are stored centrally
and and this is so there is a sort of a
radical a feedback mechanism so as more
data increases the model parameters
change they update the central repo
model parameters which in turn also
updates the parameters of a different
hospital so this is how the thing works
to discuss something what Federated
learning but again it's a very it's a
very tricky thing to implement there are
lots of expertise is needed for that
thing but there is a feeling in the
industry that things are going in with
that direction because you can't
Aggregate and store diverse
Healthcare data into a central repo
given the data sensitivity
lastly and which is where Pine biotics
and this program comes into place is
data science skills so suppose you have
data quality you have data so you have
all this data collected and created now
what you do
so so there's a tremendous lack of
Health Data literacy among healthcare
workers so any any physician any nerds
anybody they have a tremendous lack of
Health Data literacy
and skilled and even skilled data
analysts who also understand the
complexity of healthcare domain that's
also lacking so those who come from
Healthcare domain have no clue about
data science and health informatics so
that's where this sort of course is
going to help and believe me again given
the huge uh huge
I'm going to be exploitation explode
in the
uh in the genre of data science and
health health informatics this is some
skill which is going to be required in
the in this particular Health Care
industry and this is where the knowledge
and skill of various data sources
various Healthcare data sources and data
types and how to clean them how to
standardize them how to curate them how
to
conceive uh important models and how to
build those models how to test those
models and how to deploy those models
this entire skill is going to be a very
uh very rare skill in the coming future
so next I move to challenges and
opportunities so challenges wise I have
already mentioned it in a iterative
fashion again I will just mention it
so one thing is did problem in data
acquisition
so you can't get data so easily and then
because and suppose for some cases where
you have to do some real time prediction
suppose you have a person who is wearing
a Fitbit a variable from where you are
capturing the blood pressure now now the
blood pressure is dropping down
gradually and and it's dropping down
very steeply and it tells you that that
the person is going to going to have a
fall because it's it's going that it's
going down consistently now from there
you need to give a particular
notification to that patient or to to
the relevant care providers that this
patient is going to have a fall
so for that you need some real time data
streaming the data streaming and
real-time data prediction model
prediction and notification so this
entire thing this involves lots of
expertise you need database
administrations you need model
deployments you need data scientists
there are lots of things for a very
simple problem
but this is something which is a very
challenging thing
capturing and storing and predicting
from real time or near real-time data
which is very very important with
Healthcare uh Healthcare informatics
next as I already told data that
harmonizing data so you have to
standardize disease drugs symptom
procedures across different data sources
using proper ontology mapping so you
need to know that how do I standardize
disease how do I do this for drug from
where do I find the information that
which drug treats which disease which
drug should not be given in which
disease so what are all possible
relationships between drug and disease
so that is a very big area that there is
something called a medical medical
terminology and there are multiple
available ontologies and so that's also
which is very which are very important
resource to be learned for health
informatics
next comes model building now model
building uh I I guess we will be talking
more on model building so it has two
very vital steps one is feature
engineering one is model building so
feature engineering means you process
some biomedical data from different
sources it can be omic Source it can be
emrs vital variable parameters images
scans and images and you convert them to
clinical and meaningful features called
feature engineering so you just you just
translate or transform the data into
some structured features so this feature
engineering will depend on the data type
if you are using image data then you
will be extracting pixels and pixel
features if it's a colored image you
will extract
rgb3 different Channel features it's a
black and white image you will extract
only 0 to 1 to 255 black and white pixel
feature you if it's clinical notes you
will be building word embeddings
if it's a tablet data then it's already
a tabulated data you will need to
normalize it so this feature engineering
is something very important in clean in
healthcare data next comes so once you
feature once you derive the features you
can use them into the models right you
can you where you can make supervised
models and supervised models neural
networks graph Networks
another thing is after you build the
model for health informatics you also
need to provide something called
interpretability now Healthcare is a
such domain where you need to provide
the interpretation which is now being
called as interpretable AI so unless the
care provider knows that this is the
cause for which
so this is so this patient was having a
consistent drop in the blood pressure
for the last two minutes and that's why
the model has told me that he is going
to have a fall in the next five minutes
so this interpretation has to be there
in the context of healthcare informatics
or it won't be that much of Deployable
or translatable in the in the healthcare
domain so these two things are also big
challenges in the healthcare
informatics
now what are the industry roles now we
we all of you know about the
bioinformatician so who work with omics
data transcriptomics proteomics and yes
and this particular uh this particular
expertise is needed in this field also
majorly in in oncology where the idea is
to
subtype and precise subtyping of a
particular breast cancer or colorectal
cancer or any liver cancer and that will
help you to
scattered more precise therapy more
precise drug regime for particular
subtypes so omix data is also needed in
this particular industry that expertise
then something called clinical
information now this the role of this
clinical information is to work with all
possible critical data it can be
clinical nodes where the person will be
using NLP based techniques it can be
image data where deep learning images
and all those things with transfer
learning would be used
medical terminologist I have already
told about this that because there are
lots of disparate disparate data sources
and people are using different different
terms so we need to do a proper mapping
and this is what is called medical
terminology is the job profile for that
so we harmonize and we map it so that we
can combine data from disparated sources
and and get a central
source for generating insights
biomedical data curation so publicly
available is lots of data so publicly
available data proprietary biomedical
data you have to cube right and you have
to structure it that's a big uh there's
a big demand of this particular job rule
in the in the industry biomedical data
scientist so feature engineering and
building AI models for clinical decision
support is something which falls under
the JD of this particular role on data
scientist and lastly something called
Solutions architect who actually connect
all the technical technical details of
uh of a problem for business problem in
healthcare domain so suppose we want to
a company wants to build a fall
detection algorithm
and the article will tell the company
that you need these these things in this
place you need to have a remote
monitoring device you need to connect it
to a database and the database will live
stream the data this will be the models
which will be running in uh in maybe
every minute minute or every two minutes
and there will be notification on how
that had to be sent the entire
end-to-end thing is the what falls under
the domain of these Solutions architect
and there are many more Industrials in
the context of in the case of Health
informatics
I don't know so I guess I'll just end
today's discussion here and I guess I
just took
four minutes extra and any questions
I'll just I'm open to the questions
right now
thank you so much for the wonderful
presentation and we do have a few
queries in the chat and one is from uh
sakshin Bhatia he's asking why is there
an intersection between process
Automation and business management
just let me see the question
I'm pasting it in the chat once more so
that you can I I
related
okay so uh
ah so process so there was something
called business management uh okay so so
I I guess your question is why why have
I clubbed these two things Automation
and business management
so so I actually uh process process
automation this largely falls under the
domain of Hospital Administration so
business management and automating
processes uh sort of a part so
process automation helps in scalability
and scalability helps in arriving at
Better Business outcomes so that's why I
have just clubbed these two things
together yes you are sure you are right
we can also um we can also uh detach
both of these things
that maybe would be better sure thanks
thanks for the solution
so HIPAA is a guideline it's a more of a
U.S guideline and cppr is a European
Union based guideline so there are
particular guidelines for data sharing
so if you are sharing data if you are
storing data so where do you store the
data is it secure enough to prevent uh
data leakage and all those things so
those faults under the uh so suppose AWS
servers is is what people majorly use to
store the data and those are also HIPAA
compliant and so so your storage bucket
if whether it's secure enough
uh so so that data doesn't get leaked is
what uh those things so it's more of a
certification okay so it's more of a
that you are certified uh by HIPAA
bicycle and all those things
all right sir and I guess that was the
last query and uh thank you so much sir
for joining uh today's webinar uh and
thank you for taking the time out of
your hectic schedule to join us and uh
share your knowledge with us and uh with
that now we would like to move on to the
next part of today's webinar for that
I'd like to invite my colleague sonalika
to explain the program registration and
cost so over to you
thank you so much regarding I hope my
screen is visible
yes it is
already so we had a lot of queries in
the chat box regarding thing the
registration part so finally we are here
to discuss how you can register yourself
for the program introduction to biomatic
Center I am currently on this landing
page that I'd like to share the chat or
just say can you just share that
all right so on this landing page if you
scroll down just a second something has
happened to my screen is freezing up
all right so on the standing page if you
scroll down you will first of all find
the whole schedule of the program all
the session details what topics are we
going to cover for each one of these
sessions and each session has some
Associated Resources with it which
includes the courseworks and lessons and
practice sessions as well on the Onyx
logic learn portal and each session
comes up also with some collab notebooks
for you to practice with so we have just
mentioned some of the resources that you
would have to refer to as a part of each
and every session
so one is this page that you can refer
to for the schedule of the program and
also I'm going to take you to the
program page shortly to show where you
can find all the uh
personality Clips like your screen
got uh
just a second
and please share my screen
okay can can you see it now
yes
all right now it's working
thank you so much
so uh on this program page if you scroll
down you can find all the details of the
program first of all all right and along
with the program detains you also have
different payment links that maybe you
you can pay to uh first of all check out
for the specific number of days that you
would like to enroll in the program form
it could be either 45 days or 60 days or
90 days and you have two options uh to
either pay in USD if you are from us uh
country and if you are from India you
can pay it in INR as well and you have
the option to pay later as well you
simply need to click on the checkout
button for the number of days that you
would like to enroll it could be USD or
INR and then pick the option and proceed
ahead and if it is done collectively
then you are going to get some discount
I believe that would help you you with a
scholarship to get started with the
program
this was one thing and the other thing
added me I also wanted to mention here
was about the uh program page that you
can visit to and register yourself for
the specific program
now on the program page of biomedical
data science in art
you'll also find the sessions schedule
first of all and this is the program
page that the users have to refer to to
watch the recordings of the sessions and
also get along with each and every
Associated resources other courseworks
that are mentioned for each and every
session
uh thank you juicy for sharing the
program page in the chat box
now if users feel uh easy to follow
along the landing page to register
themselves they can otherwise you can
also register yourself on the program
page again you have the whole session
schedule mentioned here and you can pick
up the number of days for which you
would like to enroll yourself now let's
talk about why do we have these
different number of days that you that
you can take and enroll yourself on so
in the 45 days of the registration plan
what happens is you get the access to
all the the sessions and also the
recordings and the resources but the
duration is limited to 45 days and those
who want to work on a project and before
working on a project they want to
prepare their project Proposal with the
help of the mentor they have some ideas
that they would like to work on and they
want to work on a mini sort of project
I'll call it up where they can have a
research proposal in their hand and also
they can present their research work in
a poster presentation competition let's
say uh through this mini sort of project
then they can enroll for 60 days and if
they want to work on a full-fledged
project and maybe have a publication
towards the end of their research work
then they can enroll for 90 days as it
is evident obviously if you want to work
on a full-fledged project validated
results it it would take some time so
the resources remain the same for all of
these different types of days but it's
just the accessibility to through these
resources it would be either 45b 60 days
or 90 days based on the number of days
that you pick forward to register
yourself for the program
so that was about the registration part
you just need to click on the buy now
button and on top you can change the
currency based on the country you belong
to you can change to currency like this
and it would be of help now we also have
some scholarship opportunities for
students and also PhD Scholars who are
seeking scholarship to join the program
you can reach out to the marketing
manager Miss parshter on marketing at
the rate omicslogic.com and she will
help you with the scholarship form that
you can fill it out and then she'll let
you know what scholarship you can pick
to register yourself for the program
thank you SRI gauri for sharing the
details of the chat box
if there are any questions you can
please ask and we also had some
questions regarding certification so yes
after the completion of the program you
will be provided you will be provided
with a certificate and those who will
work on a research project after
completing their 90 days of duration
they'll also get a research fellowship
program certificate where the title of
the research project would be mentioned
followed along a letter of
recommendation if required for uh the
fourth studies or any Project work right
are there any questions if yes you can
please put in the chat box the team is
here we can help you out
all right so if you have no more
questions I think we are good to end
today's meet and we have shared the
details with you you can reach out to us
for any scholarship related queries or
if you want to enroll for these
different number of days but are not
sure how to proceed ahead you can reach
out to us and we'll be glad to assist
you thank you so much everyone for
joining have a nice day
have a nice day everyone bye